this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
ramsey personality best-selling author
and host of the ken coleman show ken
coleman is my guest today we help people
do work
that they love we help them build wealth
and create amazing relationships and
we're taking your calls about all of
those things right now the phone number
is triple eight eight two five five two
two five that's triple eight eight two
five five two two
five
simone is going to start off this hour
in buffalo new york hi simone how are
you
thank you so much for having me today
sure what's up
so basically i'm really blessed and i'm
a new college i'm gonna graduate college
in may of 2022 um and i'm kind of
blessed to be making a hundred thousand
dollars after graduation with a ten
thousand dollar signing bonus so i kind
of had two so sweet
what's your degree in
computer science way to go kiddo you
killed it yes
a college student with an actual career
i love it
yeah
um
so i guess one thing how do i like
properly make sure i use this amazing
salary to set myself up for the future
and um secondly how do i convince my
parents that i shouldn't take out a loan
for a car because i kind of wanted to
drive like a cheaper car that's like ten
thousand dollars using a sign-on bonus
but they kind of want me to take out
like a
massive car loan to get like a nice
thirty thousand dollar car or something
like that
okay um
i think you've reached a point kind of a
gone over the edge of the cliff now
in that you graduated you're 22 years
old you make a hundred thousand dollars
a year
uh you don't have to convince your
parents of anything honey
you're like an adult and stuff
i guess you're right
do what
i guess you're right i never really
thought about it that way yeah you don't
you don't need their permission no
it's your life
your money by the way too
so i mean just you know you just smile
and say mom and dad this is what i
decided to do and
thanks for your input
and by the way i may not go to the same
church you go to and
by the way i might buy a dress that's a
different color than one that you like
because i'm like an adult and stuff you
don't say that to them but that goes
through your mind right
yeah this is the part where they start
to understand that having grown children
who are grown is the hardest stage of
parenting because you don't get to tell
them what to do anymore
no that makes sense because like they
like they wanted me to like kind of do
the whole i guess stay-at-home mom thing
and stuff and um like kind of be like an
english major who like doesn't make a
lot of money
and you decide to go like be a
computer genius and stuff
you're amazing
so i mean listen i don't want you to be
unkind to your mom and dad but the the
point is you have reached the point in
your life where you no longer have to
have their permission to do
anything
it would be nice to have their approval
but sometimes they may choose to
withhold that approval
okay i mean let me just tell you how bad
it gets sometimes like rachel ordered a
tesla
this is how bad it is
and i can't do anything about it
now you need to explain to the audience
why that bothers you so much i can't
stand those cars they're not real cars
they're a battery with four wheels dave
likes to smell what i want i want a loud
muffler i'm a redneck and i don't know
how i possibly raised a daughter that
wants a battery but she did that's great
it's a big joke around our house so
the point i mean and if rachel were
sitting here she would love this
discussion too so but the point is is
that uh she did not buy the car to get
her father's approval otherwise she
would have bought a four-wheel drive
truck with loud mufflers so
um
but you see what i'm saying so you you
know
and i love her and it's fine if she gets
a tesla i don't give a crap george
bought one too i mean i don't care
everybody's got one so i don't i don't
well i know ken because you're like a
real man and stuff
but the uh
even i laughed at that one
uh dave i want to say it says a real
quick here because i simone here's
here's something and dave i want you to
weigh in on this i think this is a
situation where
like a lot of the advice we give on
money it's like make the decision now
like don't wait and then you overthink
because what happens is the the the sway
that parents have over their children is
tremendous and rightfully so and i don't
want her to wait to tell mom and dad hey
listen i'm going to buy a ten thousand
dollar car i want her to just do it and
then she informs him later buy the car
yes yeah yeah and pay cash for whatever
you buy yeah and then move up in car
later you're making a hundred thousand
you don't have to drive a 10 000 car
you can get a better car with cash later
as you go along and we're going to give
you a graduation present i want you to
go through financial peace university is
my gift
so we'll teach you how to handle money
you ask another question in the call of
what is the best process the best
process is to stay away from debt it
sounds like you have
get out of debt stay away from debt have
an emergency fund and begin to invest
long term
in your retirement account honey if you
are very careful if you're reasonably
wise you're going to be unbelievably
wealthy
but if you go spend 110 000 while you
make 100 like you're in congress or
something then
you know you're going to have all kinds
of issues and lots of people do that so
no i don't want you to have a car
payment
and uh if i were in your shoes if i woke
up in your shoes i would not advise you
to buy a brand new car
and i would advise you to be kind to
your mom and dad and
grateful to them for what they've done
for you and all those kinds of things
but they no longer
have
a
vote
that's how it works
and um you know
if you need their advice on something
you can ask their advice and they can
give advice but they don't have to be
convinced for you to do
anything you do and you can sense that
she
knew that they weren't right yeah and
she's kind of going how do i this was a
respect question she's a respectful
young lady it shows the power that
parents have and dave i just wonder at
what point culturally you know did it
become a thing where you got it's a
reasonable decision to take out a loan
for the dependability
of a new car
1960s
i made that up but somewhere around
there yeah i was curious car payments
became a thing in the six that's what i
was wondering when that became a
normality in the 50s and 40s there were
no car payments henry ford detested debt
huh he hated debt i did not know that if
he understood that ford motor company
made more money on
than ford does afford more credit makes
more money than ford does he would have
been just
spinning in his grave you know i mean
uh and so you know that generation j.c
penney
was nicknamed james cash penny
he was tight he hated debt
and their credit cards on the jcpenney
at one point made more money than the
stores made
and so it's uh you know it's it's a
change in in the way
debt has been marketed so aggressively
that it's become
the norm and this idea that
a
newer car
with a payment is less dangerous than a
payment right that's uh that's an
interesting
shift that has occurred but
you know if you're the parent of a
college student you're younger than me
because my kids are all older than that
so there you go or you could be
likely younger than me
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free homeownership and churchill is
here to help go to their site
churchillmortgage.com ramsey to start
your approval or get more information
[Music]
so
well guys if you're wondering whether to
buy or sell a home this year we've got
some answers you can expect the market
to be a lot like last year with prices
still on the rise but interest rates are
headed up too so what does that mean for
you if you're buying a home you might be
up against some heavy competition hefty
price tags higher interest rates higher
mortgage payments you'll need to stick
to your budget
if you want to sell your home chances
are it'll sell quickly and for top
dollar and of course it'll depend on
where you are because every market's
different but to win in any kind of
market uh you gotta have people on your
corner that really know what they're
doing if you have an arre
if you have experienced real estate
agents at your fingertips through our
endorsed local provider program as
ramsey trusted pros they care about your
values check out ramseysolutions.com
agent and connect with ramsey trusted
pro
not the type of real estate market boys
and girls that is amateur hour
bad idea to do this yourself or to get
someone who's been in the business 20
minutes to be dealing with a transaction
in this crazy world we live in right
this section second amy is with us amy
is in seattle hi amy welcome to the
ramsay
show good afternoon mr randy and mr
coleman thank you for taking my calls
sure um
i i'm a little nervous english is not my
first language but i hope i can
communicate today you're doing good so
far
i'm a 42 year old single mom of a 10
year old son
living in seattle washington
and i started on a good paying job um
about five years ago only after moving
from florida to washington and since
then i have been i think i've been doing
everything right financially following
on your baby steps
um and i'm a baby step five actually um
i don't have any debt
uh but you know at some point i do want
to buy a home for myself and my son
but i just cannot catch up with the
price increase every time i think i can
get to the 20 down payment
the market just beats me
and i can never you know i feel like i'm
at a dead end and
this year my rent has also gone up 21
i i really did not have an option to
relocate at this point
um
so i just wanted to get your advice i
don't have family here in the states
so
i just i don't know what what can i do
what what should i do at this point okay
what do you make
i'm making 145k
a year okay how much have you saved
for a down payment
um i can put in at least um 150k
okay
150k
so i
so the houses over here they are
the houses that i look around over here
are like 1.2 to 1.3 million well you're
not buying that house you can't afford
that and that's not the median house
price in seattle by the way
so
that is not the median house price this
is a fact i'm giving you
1.2 is not the median house price in
seattle washington
right but the location that i've been
looking for you can't afford
yes exactly so buy in a location you can
afford in
um that's true
there is one catch to it uh mr anthony
uh
i think that i should tell you is
since i'm a single mom and i have no
family school district is very important
to me
and really any decent school district
here is at least 1.2 million if i'm not
looking at hoa so
you know the hoas themselves are 700 to
800 dollars around the decent school
district so
you know if the prices are around 800k
then the hoas are on 700 to 800k a month
otherwise if i buy a standalone without
an hoa it is you know it goes past 1.2
1.3 million dollars what do you do for a
living
um i work as a content strategy with a
company
you have paralysis of the analysis girl
you have narrowed this decision down to
where you have no movement
and there is no way on the planet
that 1.2 million makes sense in your
budget
you don't get a pass on math because you
have a certain school district that you
have locked your eyes in on
and
you know i i do not know the school
districts in seattle but it is hard for
me to believe
that a hundred percent of the school
districts in the six hundred thousand
dollar neighborhood which is the median
house price by the way half of what
you're looking at are all horrible
so your decision-making paradigm is what
your problem is it's not the real estate
market and it's not your income
you've narrowed down you you've created
a fatalistic situation where you think
you have to live in this one
neighborhood that you can't afford to
live in
and so it's like the only possible car
is a bentley well you and you can't
afford a bentley
yeah well and i think also you heard in
there because i'm a single mother i have
no family there's some there's some
false narrative stuff in there that's
saying that if you don't put your kid in
the absolute best school district or two
if you're ranking the top five you've
got this idea that you're not a good mom
you're not doing for your son what you
should be doing and that again is a
false narrative
and so once we can destroy that look at
what's behind that false narrative dave
it's fear fear that i'm not being a good
mother by putting him in this school
district and now that's where we get to
the well we're trying to rationalize i'm
paying this much for a house
because i got to be a good mom so that's
where it gets off amy the language that
you're using is as if you make 45 000 a
year
not 145
which you would not have choices
in seattle washington
to buy
in a lot of areas most areas
at that income if your household income
is 45 000 very difficult to live in the
metroplex in seattle it's an expensive
market or denver or manhattan or san
francisco you know you just you can't
the math you don't get a pass on math
but you make 145 and you talk like you
make no money
and and so um i mean you're not rich i'm
not saying that i'm not saying you don't
have problems i'm not saying the budget
isn't tight but um you've managed to
save a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars
not buying
is going to continue cut to watch those
house prices go up faster than your
savings goes up
and so i i would start looking for a
house
that i can afford and um that's what i
would do and you're not a bad mom
so um had a young lady do a debt-free
scream not long ago um grew up with a
single mom and subsidized housing in the
hood
and uh you know she makes really really
good money now she she managed to
survive all of that and and you know her
mom was a warrior princess that fought
through and took care of those kids and
did it on almost nothing and
made almost no money and they weren't in
a great neighborhood and weren't grade
schools i'm sure
and uh yeah she comes out here and she's
making six figures and her life is great
because you know her mom modeled warrior
for her
and um you know that's what we're
challenging to do miss amy i think you
can do this evan is in denver high evan
welcome to the ramsay show
hey dave how are you doing better than i
deserve what's up
so my wife and i are 24 years old and we
are on baby step six go ahead um
baby step five doesn't apply to us yes
just because we don't have kids
so in the meantime
i'm trying to decide whether i want to
pay off my home early or do i want to
invest more
and my when i do the math on it
um
it's just to me at the interest rate i
have
uh does not make any sense to pay off my
home early the opportunity cost of not
investing is much greater
than paying off the home early okay
and so i'd just be wondering
you know
what when i'm trying to build wealth
why should i focus on wondering why i
taught this this way for 30 years and
you figured out i was wrong
[Music]
somewhat yeah
[Laughter]
okay
well we the the latest piece of data
that has confirmed that this teaching is
correct
is that we studied the largest number of
millionaires ever studied in north
america 10 167 of them
them being millionaires was primari
primarily consisted mathematically of
two things uh a large
beefy 401k roth ira
retirement plan and good mutual funds
and a paid for house
and a lot of them did that and by the
way in their 30s
which you could probably still do
but if you want if if your theory is is
that by
not paying off your house thus borrowing
on a house to become wealthy
works why don't you borrow as much as
you possibly can on the house
i mean borrow more than it's worth on
the house at the low interest rate and
invest it
if your theory works but see when i ask
you that question you suddenly
experienced in your heart risk
which your question did not
give me enough
told me that you don't have an
understanding of risk
you get your house paid off son your
life is going to move a lot faster
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsay right now to get their free white
paper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today best-selling author open
phones this hour triple eight eight two
five five two two five in the lobby of
ramsey solutions on the debt free stage
ben and erica are with us hey guys how
are you doing well how are you better
than i deserve where do you guys live by
saya california whoa bit of a hall to
tennessee a little bit wow well welcome
good to have you and all the way over
here to do a debt-free scream how much
did you pay off we paid off 429 000 in
seven years yeah like this and your
range of income during that seven years
we started at 65 and last year had our
biggest year we went over 300. whoa what
do y'all do for a living we're both
veterinarians oh wonderful yeah good
year to be a veterinarian yeah thanks
for
lots of people looking at their puppies
during pandemic and going help yeah
absolutely wow crazy so 429 over seven
years that's a small amount for a
mortgage in california but was that your
mortgage it was not that was all student
loans oh of course
two veterinarians two two dvms uh yeah
okay all right
a lot it was like a mortgage yeah wow
what a nice house we could have yeah for
real
well you got a great career instead so
there we go seven
years what started this journey
i grew up in a ramsey household i didn't
realize it until later um so i knew from
the moment that i got a student loan i
didn't feel like i had any other option
but i knew from the moment that i got it
that i wanted it gone
so i listened to the dave ramsey show
constantly
brought him along for the ride
introduced him to the name he was
familiar with the principles
and then the moment we got married we
decided to go for it so you've been
married seven years we haven't all right
just like that knock it out yep and uh
that that is a long time to get rid of a
large student loan but it is a large
student loan so that's you you crunched
your way through it how does it feel to
be free oh it's so amazing incredible
yeah you've got to know some other docs
out there that are still struggling oh
yeah
we had a lot of colleagues tell us why
are you bothering with this just keep it
around and just pay the payments on it
and live your life well the joke is i
always say keep it around like it's a
pet haha for a vet right that's ironic
oh yeah that's the irony of that yeah
but yeah
the joke is the vets keep it around like
it's a pet yeah that's it that's even
worse not you guys uh you you got rid of
old sallie mae you gave her eviction
notice
so what is the key to paying off 429 000
in seven years i think the biggest thing
for us is um just recognizing that it's
it's not our money like we're just
stewards of what we've been graced with
and and being able to just recognize
that and hold holding money with an open
hand and trusting just the whole process
we we've seen that um just being
faithful has been so beneficial to us
and to the people around us
so you started this journey after
getting married so this is this is kind
of hey we're learning how to be married
and then we're learning how to do this
finance stuff the right way i'm just
curious was there a moment in the seven
years where you finally got to a place
of okay there's some real momentum here
despite struggles despite stuff coming
your way you're going okay we see the
finish line no matter what our
colleagues are saying we see this
it actually wasn't until the last couple
of years so um the first probably five
years were drudgery
between me being in school and him
working
so he's trying to support us and do this
and then we lived and lived overseas for
a period of time and
made not very much money all things
considered and then it wasn't until
really the last two or three years where
we finally
we had no you know certain loans getting
under three under six digits and we
thought okay there's hope here so you
caught another gear then this last the
last half yeah yeah way to go guys very
good way to go heroes yeah man you took
control of your life how's it feel to be
free oh it's the best thing ever
we cried when it happened oh my goodness
now i assume you guys work together is
that the correct assumption or separate
business no we're separate businesses
really i primarily do dairy cattle and
beef feedlot and erica does small animal
really so are you in an agricultural
area then of california
where is vasaya it's south of fresno
right in the central valley oh yeah
you're right in the middle okay all the
dairy cows all around us so the best
part of this season is that being
debt-free has facilitated a transition
for ben out of full-time veterinary work
into
part-time veterinary work part-time
ministry oh wow cool
good for you guys well you can do
anything you want to do now right
absolutely free you don't have to serve
two masters exactly exactly it's good
good for you guys well done well done
and you uh you brought the kiddos let's
have them come up what are their names
and ages so if adeline she's three
george is one and we actually have a
third on the way so
hey
who were your biggest cheerleaders
outside the two of you while you walked
through this for seven years uh this guy
over here this is my dad he's been a
massive
help and support and cheerleader for us
but really our families were all
incredibly supportive through the
process which was really helpful very
cool very cool so yeah if you're a
financial peace baby then dad's
definitely proud and definitely cheering
you on that's very good
good stuff well done you guys very well
done we've got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you that's the next
chapter in your story for sure how
ordinary people build extraordinary
wealth how you can too and of course
getting some help with
microphone it i know that's why we don't
of a temptation the
put them in the shot until the very end
and i blew it i put them up there too
soon so uh but anyway yeah a copy of uh
the total money makeover for you to give
away and stir up a ruckus with somewhere
so good stuff ben and erica addy and
georgia from california 429 000 a couple
of veterinarians with both their debts
cleared in seven years making 65 to 300.
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
three
[Applause]
i love it
that is so
fun
well done you guys
absolutely absolutely incredible
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
speaking of california debbie's in
riverside hi debbie what's up
hey how are you guys better than we
deserve
how can we help
so
we live in california which we hate
we're moving um but my husband and i we
just sold our home that's a whole
different story for another day um but
my husband and i we just sold our home
california dream we um sold it for a
double for what we paid for it
um and now our problem is
um i've paid when covet hit i lost my
job so our credit cards got behind the
big ones that you know the two three
four seven thousand dollar
um credit lines got behind
um i was still able to pay off the
smaller ones that were 20 a month you
know whatever
um so since we just sold the house last
week i've paid off all the current
credit cards
which is only like four thousand dollars
maybe five thousand
um i still have about 50 000 in student
loans and um
we have about because of the credit
cards that we we stopped paying on
because we couldn't afford it
um we have probably about 20 000
worth of charge off
um just stuff on our credit and we
really just want to be able to buy a
home again out of state
and get our credit fixed and just get
back to
you know hopefully
forever being debt-free but i mean we're
i would love to do that
so how much proceeds do you have left
from the home
um right now we have about uh before i
pay off any other bills probably about
230 000. okay and you know roughly what
your balances were before they were
written off right
yeah yeah we get in touch with them get
in touch with them and
get them to give you a number in writing
that is about what those balances were
that doesn't have a bunch of added stuff
to it
and so if you had a card that had 10 000
don't let them try to charge you 15.
get them to get them to give it in
writing at this 10 and you'll pay it off
and then send them a check once you've
got it in writing that the payoff is x
and you're actually going to have to
argue with them to be able to get that
in writing and get it paid off if you'll
give me a balance that isn't close to
the balance that i had when this thing
was written off i will write you a check
today and you have to have that
conversation 63 times it's going to be
unbelievably aggravating and then you'll
be debt-free when you make the move
you're going to have to rent for a year
your credit is seriously damaged you're
not going to get a mortgage you're not
going to get a mortgage except at a
ridiculous subprime rate and i would not
do that so go rent for a year let your
credit heal you're 100 debt free with
your rent paid on time for a year
your credit
score will start to disappear start to
heal
and you can work your way through into a
good mortgage at that point so but
you're not going to make a move into a
mortgage not if not not with what you've
done to your credit
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
thank you for joining us america ken
coleman ramsey personality is my co-host
today kaylee is with us in fort worth
texas hey kaley welcome to the ramsey
show
hi there how are y'all doing better than
we deserve how can we help
well y'all i'm tired
um
i i have a bachelor's and a master's
degree in biology and i'll tell you all
right now that master's in biology is
the biggest mistake i ever made
i am currently working as a non-profit
as a supervisor i've been here for about
three years and i am i really want to
quit my job
i'm not enjoying my work anymore i feel
like i've been sidelined i don't feel
appreciated
um but i'm i'm too afraid to quit i've
got my husband who
he wouldn't be able to take care of all
of us if we were uh if i were to quit
and then i've got a 10 month old baby
boy and so
i'm not really sure where to go food and
go where to go from here
well let's first deal with the fear
there's nothing for you to be afraid of
because you're not going to quit without
something to walk into okay yeah so
let's just go ahead and let's remove all
of that because you're not going to do
that you have responsibilities and while
you're burned out let's be grateful in
this next season whatever that length of
time is going to be let's focus on being
grateful that's how you hang on i'm
grateful for the check i'm going to be a
good steward of the time there because
i've got to be so stability is the thing
we're grateful for for 30 to 60 days
while you land something that's it all
right so okay let me ask you before ken
goes on let me ask you this okay
what do you make
i'm gonna make 15 hours okay so
you find a job that pays the equivalent
of
30 an hour
doing something that as you look at it
makes you excited and makes you smile
and you take that job
and you accept the position that they
offer you
there is no fear if that happens in
quitting is there
no there would be like a celebration not
a fear
right absolutely confetti
dancing out the whole thing right
right okay ken yeah
so i think you have some ideas
and i think that you're a little bit
concerned about what that looks like to
step into that so let's suspend all
doubt and all fear of stepping in
something else i mean get two degrees
you have a lot of experience and you
have a lot of talent true or false
uh i'm
true i believe yes you do okay so what
have you thought about that you're just
not sure of how you would get there but
you wonder about it you let your mind
wander to say you know what would that
be like to do this kind of work i think
you have some ideas give me one or two
um
we all i think the main thing is i feel
like i need to
go outside of what i've put my education
into i've um and that's okay so tell me
the idea it's possible
yeah um
well
i love to be a stay-at-home mom
i love to uh
do
like
at home tutoring i love to
and
i've had a slight inclination about
going into ministry okay why tell me the
why think about the people and the
problem that you want to solve for those
people i want you to just tell me that
type of work if i could pay you 30 an
hour today
and you're doing this type of work what
is it don't overthink this it's right
there you've already let it run through
your head about three times while we've
been talking just say it what would you
do because you have to work right now
so what would you do what would you
really enjoy doing if you knew the money
was there say it
i love to write
okay
okay and you love to create you love to
create content to help people so so what
we've got to figure out here is what's
the central problem that you're writing
for or you might be in ministry for
there's a pattern here when you say
ministry when you say tutoring when you
say writing there's a thread that
connects all of those ideas do you
believe that
i think i absolutely know so
so what is it
what is that writing the ministry the
instructing because that at home
tutoring is a form of coaching or
instructing so there's there's an
equipping side of you you want to help
people
move from a to b is that still true am i
still on the track here with you
yes sir okay so i won't put you on the
spot anymore because i know you're live
and everything but there's a here's what
i want you to hear
there is a clear connection between
those three ideas and it's about a
certain group of people and here's the
questions you've got to answer i'm going
to give you the homework assignment and
then i'm going to give you an assessment
that's going to fast forward the
homework here's the homework i want you
to think about those three ideas that
you named and i want you to think who do
i really want to help well now with the
at-home tutoring or tutoring students
that's a pretty clear answer ministry
there's an answer there and then of
course writing when you write something
it's to write to entertain or it's to
write to inform or it's to write to
equip like the kind of writing that
ramsay personalities do so you always
look at who are the people that i really
want to help
what problem do they have or desire they
have that draws me into that group of
people and then the solutions to that
problem or desire therein lies the ideas
for the type of work the specific job or
specific career path does that make
sense
right yeah okay so that's your homework
assignment here's what i know if i
continually i'm asking who are the
people i want help problem i want to
solve solution i want to provide ideas
are going to present themselves and i'm
going to see things that i may not have
seen before
and so what happens next is i get clear
there now i'm looking at what do i want
to do and i choose okay i want to do
this more than i want to do this it's a
season of life i've got to work i when i
decide that i can go home part time and
the husband and i are on the same page
financially then we can go what's a
part-time version of that same set of
answers and so that's your progression
so right now we want to get you clear on
the types of jobs that you would be
fulfilled in
and then we go what do i need to do to
get qualified all right and in those
three things you have to specifically
look into it what do i need to do learn
how much is that going to cost how long
will that take and now we can see here's
a path forward and we're not so
overwhelmed
now if you once you identify all of that
then that's going to take you all the
way through the process to
uh actually identify jobs that do those
things and then go get one of those jobs
and then quit
and it'll be more fifteen dollars an
hour no question and you know you just
got you've worked through the process so
you don't land
back in something else that's
frustrating
and quote burned out and all that kind
of a thing
um and so
yeah hang on kelly's gonna pick up uh
we're gonna give you a copy of ken's um
assessment process and it's a 30 process
to take the test but we're giving it to
you yeah and you can take this
assessment you take it just a few
minutes and it'll give you a real clear
the takeaways from that assessment can
are really important yeah what happens
is you get a full report on what you do
best people talk about skills here and
then the type of work you love and then
what motivates you in other words the
results that when your work produces
this result at ramsey solutions all of
us everybody in the building our work
produces
hope transformational content that
people can use to practically change
their life and so when you get that
report then we put it in a purpose
statement and what we love about the
purpose statement dave is what we're
hearing from people that use the
assessment is that it becomes a 30 000
foot view think of in an airplane i'm
looking down
and i can see multiple specific jobs and
those descriptions and i look and i say
do they match up with my purpose
statement and that gives us confidence
to say okay i know i can do this now the
assessment also even throws out some
possible it actually gives you
possibilities we hold this very loosely
because it's impossible
anybody that tells you that they can
predict what career you should do with
an assessment is lying to you
they can cause you to predict it they
can allow you to look and we give you
suggestions and so it's a wonderful tool
let's also kelly give her the book from
paycheck to purpose because this is the
companion if you will
once you know the mountaintop you want
to scale this will help you guide you up
the mountain but i will tell you dave
there's one other suggestion here when i
hear that somebody's really burned out
there's a lot of factors going on
and if we know we don't want to stay
there but we're just looking for a
bridge
you know you can go get a better paying
job that is temporary day job meaning
i'm not invested in it but it's going to
pay me 25 30 bucks an hour as a bridge
while i'm
seeking the ultimate path yeah that's a
suggestion you can go do that
i probably would give 30 days a job
hunter 45 days a job
for the main position first sure but if
that doesn't work you know like by the
end of the summer by september i'll just
take a 25 an hour job at target yeah
because that's thinking what they're
paying
so uh get your 40 hours and how you can
feed your family while you land in the
big job again that puts us our the
ramsey show in the box
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where dad
is dumb cash is king and the paid off
home mortgage has taken the place of the
bmw as the status symbol of choice ken
coleman ramsey personality is my co-host
today open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
we help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships thank you for being here
america
ken is going to start off this hour he's
in houston texas if i was to push the
right button he would be there he is hey
ken how are you
oh good how are you better than i
deserve what's up
um i'm gonna graduate college in about
three weeks
and i hope you on a certain season i
wanted your opinion on um
planning basically what i'm going to be
doing pretty far
to start out
i'm looking for a
government or a state job i plan on
probably teaching high school
or some type of education
and
i'm in a unique situation right now
where um
i'm fortunate enough to have a
house um basically paid off in my name
but my problem is you know as a new
adult i've always wanted to
move out into my own space
and i know
inflation is up right now
but i was trying to
see if it's a smart idea to possibly
rent out my current um residency and
look for a place to stay on my own
or if i should just stay put and um
start saving for um something more
long-term
okay you said you want to live on your
own but you have a house that's paid for
who's living in the house with you
my dad lives here um with me but it's um
but it's like i'm usually i'm here most
of the time by myself the reason i want
to move out is just because of the area
this is really
where's your dad gonna go
oh he um he
has another um place that he studied
he really just comes to visit
like weekly just to make sure i'm like
doing okay
is the house in your name
yeah
sell it mm-hmm
where do you want to move to what are
you in a rough area or just an area you
grew up in and you're just looking for
change
where do you want to go to and then how
what's the cost of living analysis there
how close is it give us a little bit
more information there
well it's just the um house i grew up in
but it's um it's a low income area so it
just comes with um
those type of problems there's just no
it's one of those areas where you can't
like you know just go outside and take a
walk you know
um okay you need to sell it you need to
sell it
okay it's not going to get better you're
not going to live in it it's not going
to be a great piece of real estate to
own uh because of the area you need to
sell it and take the money and start
your fresh life
so you're 22 or 23. and
yes i'm 22.23 at the end of the summer
cool what's your degree in
uh sociology with a minor in education
okay and why why work for the state
well i know um the state has i've not
heard no but i've heard that they have
good benefits and i want to do something
in social work and um help people
and that is something that um probably
or most likely find
high satisfaction in as a career
okay when are you getting this job
because you graduate in three weeks
yeah i'm right now um i'm in like the
last three weeks so i'm crunching down
on um
my last assignment from one of my um
sociology advisors
going to help me um start you know
applying for um
for jobs yeah you're like six months
late on that you should already be doing
that
okay what are you what are you using for
food money now
uh basically right now
i'm living off savings and i wanted to
[Music]
basically do that until like i had my
degree so
and
like get something established like on
some ground
basically like you know some something
a stable income i've been
um trying to
get my degree and then start living on a
stable income and once i started my
stable and come up um was debating on
whether
it would be a good idea to like
move out and start living on my own off
of that or if i could just like
stay where i'm at um no you shouldn't
believe in yourself i've already told
you that you should leave and you should
sell the house and you should buy a
house that you start your whole fresh
life over
you've been through something really
traumatic that gave you a bunch of money
what happened
uh
well basically um when i was going
through my mom's hospital
and that left you a bunch of money
uh
it was
me and a couple other family members but
um
it was
i'm sorry
it's
okay
um like
the cure for someone um you know on my
feet throughout college yeah yeah
okay so here here's what um
i i was hearing the heaviness in your
voice and then i hear you got a paid for
house and a pile of money that you're
living on and you're 23. so i knew
something was up those were my clues
okay
but the heaviness in your voice was my
first clue
so ken i think your voice is going to
brighten up because your life is going
to brighten up when this horrible
event is put for as far in the rear view
mirror as you can put it in the rearview
mirror not to say it didn't happen and
not to say it doesn't hurt it does hurt
but you've been being defined by this
for a long time and living off the
savings and living in that house is
trapping you
in this event
so i want you living on your own income
and in a different house with that house
sold as soon as possible to brighten
your life up
and to move past this horrible thing
that has happened to you okay
okay um i have one follow-up question
though
i like this thing where
i haven't wanted to
physically consider exactly what um area
i wanted to
have a house in because just go rent
just go rent something yeah
that's all that's
for a year until you get settled into
your new job
and and i want you to go ahead and start
working on the new job as soon as you
get off the phone and we're going to
send you a copy of ken's book from
paycheck to purpose yeah i i would just
add uh two things on the living space
houston's a really large area a lot of
nicer places what i want to do is go
explore go literally drive around i
think there's you've been through a lot
of trauma and you've been head down on
this degree let's go explore a little
bit second thing is don't just rely on
your college advisor to help you apply i
want you looking in those areas where
you might may want to live in where are
some social working type jobs and let's
begin to go investigate talk to people
and meet some folks and see what's out
there this is a fresh start that you
need i wouldn't wait anymore i'd make it
your full-time assignment go go go the
best is yet to be we're going to send
you a copy of john dolone's new book as
well
on your past change your future because
that's exactly what we're talking to you
about owning your past and changing your
future this is the ramsey shack
[Music]
um
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry it's
worth it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it is book launch week ken coleman
ramsey personality is my co-host today
dr john dolone's new book
wow
own your past change your future i just
gave away one a minute ago is now
available for purchase john is out on
the road
again
and doing the book tour thing
very cool stuff and we've got him on the
line to check in in phoenix arizona dr
john how's phoenix
it is beautiful and hot how are you guys
it is hot it is definitely hot this time
of the year we're great what have you
been doing today
we did some radio stops and a stop at a
local tv station and now we are at a
beautiful movie theater the majestic
here we're going to spend the afternoon
with the dutch brothers having a good
time all right dutch brothers coffee is
a wonderful organization and they've
been good friends to the entree
leadership team for a long time and they
ask you to come in and speak right
yes sir looking forward to it yeah very
cool stuff and tonight we'll be doing
john will be doing a book signing there
in phoenix arizona barnes and noble
desert ridge marketplace tatum boulevard
and that's at six o'clock tonight
thursday night april the 21st uk tiara
ktar listeners run out and see dr john
deloney uh there'll be a bunch of folks
out there and john will be talking for a
few minutes i guess and doing a little q
a maybe right
yes sir we'll be uh talking for a few
minutes doing some q a and then signing
everybody's books and taking some
pictures and just laughing and having a
good old time very cool fun stuff fun
stuff
well the uh the media has certainly
accepted the premise on this new book
the uh public certainly has
it has sold we've sold tens of thousands
of them in the pre-sale process and of
course it officially went on sale on
tuesday congratulations on having a big
hit
thank you so so much and it's not lost
on me that uh
the listeners here have just been so
great and responsive and so
on behalf of me and all the team that
worked on this and you thank you all so
much for for your support and for
picking the book up
so the book is called own your past
change your future
uh remind the audience what they get
what the book is about what's what we're
talking about there
really i get calls from all over the
country and direct messages and emails
hey can i
can i be your therapist or can i sit
down and coach people or would you sit
with me and my spouse and really this
book is what i would say this is two
decades worth of sitting with people and
really me having to talk to
professionals myself along the way
because i've had my own struggles and
trying to figure out being a dad and
reading the right books and talking to
my wife
how are we going to figure out how to
own what has happened to us and ask that
one scary terrifying question
what happens now what do i do next right
and so that's what this book is it's
teaching us how to own what happened and
then make the next right step yeah own
your past
change your future and we just had a
young man on an earlier segment ken and
i did who
obviously we didn't get into the details
but obviously been through a lot of
trauma
and um
had a huge financial settlement as a
result
and it was weighing him down the whole
process was weighing him down and we
actually gave him a copy of the book
because you know the whole idea of
owning his past and yet changing his
future not not being defined by
the event the trauma
that's right it may be the most common
common thing i hear is i just feel stuck
i feel stuck especially after last few
years i just feel like i'm going through
the motions me and my wife are just
going through the motions of me and my
kids me and my local schools to me and
my local whatever just going to emotions
how do i get unstuck what do i do next
yeah that's what this book that's this
book is for you if you're stuck
you know john i can't help but think
that when readers get this and they
understand what you've just said
that at the beginning of the arduous
process of trying to own the past that's
hard work and you show people how to do
it but there's such a bright future on
the other side isn't there
yeah that's the thing that i really want
to get through on this this is a book
about hope this is a book
basking in the light at the end of this
tunnel most of us just don't realize
we're in a tunnel right and you can you
and i've talked about this just
personally
we just come to accept that life as we
get older the light just gets dimmer and
dimmer and dimmer and i'm just calling
nonsense on that there is hope hope hope
out there and when you own it and then
you can begin to take those steps into
the light man ah such a great experience
it's true no wait don't don't walk
toward the light
yeah yeah not you don't tell people my
age to walk toward the light okay yeah
not you me and ken can walk towards your
life
john if he says he starts seeing the
light right now you're gonna see me
tackle him
hug him do something to get that light
to go away
[Laughter]
you call 9-1-1 ken you and i are young
enough to walk towards the light dave
needs to stay put
[Laughter]
close enough
got a front row seat baby uh phoenix
arizona john dr john dolone the new book
is own your past change your future
he'll be signing it tonight at the
desert ridge marketplace tatum boulevard
barnes noble be out there at six o'clock
you'll laugh you'll cry you'll learn you
can ask questions and of course pick up
a copy of the book and get it signed by
the author himself his two phds his 20
years of crisis counseling and working
in uh high stress scenarios is really
giving him some insight that uh that
will be helpful to any of us uh
regardless of 100 of us have something
in our past we need to own that we don't
need to stuff and act like it's not
there it's like a splinter uh as our
friend les parrott says he says when you
bury feelings like that they have a high
rate of resurrection
so uh yeah they'll come back up and
they'll come back up in the worst
possible ways and so
getting getting on with your life by
owning your past changing your future is
what dr john delaney's all about so be
sure and check him out john we're very
proud of you brother congratulations
i'm grateful for you too and for
everybody listening who picked up a copy
and i'm i'm just been it's been a
humbling process man i'm really grateful
hey john tell those guys at dutch bros
that ken wants a bag of coffee if you
can stuff one of those in your suitcase
on the way back that'd be great
oh i'm going to bring back oh yeah i'm
going to get a second suitcase i'm
bringing some coffee back
yeah there we go i'm going to pick up
one of the flea markets just one just
one for me that'd be great
all right john thank you brother
congratulations very very well done
all right one of the most important
types of insurance you can have is car
insurance it's actually the law by the
way most americans don't have enough car
insurance sometimes they're paying too
much for the wrong stuff and you might
be one of them if you get in an accident
this is not the time to find out you
don't have enough coverage you need to
get coverage right now and have it
checked out you don't want thousands of
dollars to be a problem because of 20 a
month or you could even be saving 20 a
month and getting more insurance so
here's the deal this is why we created a
network of endorsed local providers that
are ramsey trusted these are licensed
independent insurance agents that will
shop a bazillion companies and get you
the best possible coverage at the
cheapest possible price the average
person calling and getting a quote saves
an average of seven hundred dollars a
year on their car and homeowners
insurance get in touch with them go to
ramseysolutions.com
auto and you can connect with a ramsey
trusted
p our question of the day comes from
blinds.com find out for yourself why
blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings you
get free samples free shipping and new
promos all the time use the promo code
ramsey to get the best possible deal
today's question comes from cody in
north carolina i was recently married
and we just found out we have a baby on
the way i'm in my second year selling
real estate and my projected sales goal
would provide enough money to pay the
bills my concern is whether or not i
meet my goal i have experience in
plumbing and have an opportunity to go
back into that field at 20 to 25 an hour
if real estate goes well for me this
year i could make much more but i'm not
sure if the risk is worth it the
downside of plumbing is
i would always be on call worrying about
making enough money has enveloped my
life which path should i take
well dave i don't know where you're
gonna go on this one but i think cody uh
needs to stop worrying about what won't
happen and focus on what could happen
this is a guy who you've got plumbing to
fall back on cody so there's actually
nothing to really be afraid of if for
some reason and i can't find a a viable
reason other than you just deciding not
to be committed and convicted and get
after it meet those goals
you could fall back to plumbing and the
trades are very much hot they need
qualified people you could potentially
pick up some side work plumbing as well
but i just don't think that's going to
be necessary i think you're fearful
because all of a sudden we got a baby on
the way but you have a bright future i'd
focus all that energy on providing for
that baby not worrying about not meeting
my goals is your goal realistic did you
make zero last year and you said a
hundred thousand dollars is your goal
this year well that would not be true
unless something bizarre happens
so you need to ask yourself what has to
be true for you to hit this goal if what
has to be true is reasonable then you
keep doing the real estate
if you're living a fairy tale then you
go do some plumbing for a while you
gotta feed the baby this is the ramsey
shop
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage alan and anya are with
us hey guys how are you great doing
great great welcome where do you guys
live long beach california all the way
to nashville to do a debt-free scream
how much did you pay off
690 000.
and how long did this take
nine years 11 months wow oh suspiciously
like 10 years wow and your range of
income during the decade uh we started
right around 200
and and last year we were up over 400
and um with a lot of overtime so now
we're backing it back down again good
for you what do you guys do for a living
my goodness
i i'm a um ramsay certified financial
coach
and i operate heavy equipment in the
port of long beach ah yeah both of you
doing well congratulations thank you and
working a lot
absolutely yeah yeah there was a whole
bunch of people waiting on you
i had a line back up there i did my best
it wasn't your fault it wasn't your
fault but yeah that was a deal the same
thing about all those ships that were
lined up is that still the case or is it
no okay good you got caught up yes yeah
all that a lot of ot though huh
absolutely i bet i bet so what kind of
debt was the
690 000 is that the house
um it was a little bit of everything we
had a credit card we had a heloc we had
a truck loan and we had um
what was it personal loan oh yeah we had
a personal loan and then we had three
mortgages three mortgages why not yeah
why not california absolutely all right
so you're 100
free debt-free house and everything
everything we're looking at weird people
i love it congratulations you guys and a
decade of hustling grind
like you said it's a marathon yeah for
real that's amazing so tell us the story
what starts you on a decade long journey
to be a hundred percent free
um our church our road church in long
beach was offering fpu yeah and they had
free child care
so we had a three and a seven-year-old
at the time
so it sounded like a night off for me
so i said let's do this yeah and i said
yes dear
yeah good man
so free babysitter that's the hook okay
who knew yeah there we go all right and
you go in there and you go okay my night
off just turned into uh uh oh i now have
another i now have an assignment
absolutely well you know it's all about
the communication that's
you know that's the key to it really
it's about setting that time aside and
um being intentional
yeah big deal congratulations so do you
remember back
10 years ago the lessons there were 13
lessons then
um
how far into the class before you went
oh game on we got to do this um i'm
pretty stubborn it i took the class
twice okay
so the second time yeah we're going
through it how far into the can
okay
about halfway through okay yeah all
right all right kind of you remember the
light switch going on yes i do a little
little yeah light bulb over your head
cha-ching right yeah
i remember those moments in my life at
different things yeah it's it's pretty
incredible and so how long have you been
a a ramsay coach on you um i started
last year i've led four sessions of fpu
and um then i i said you know i need to
deep digger sorry to dig deeper into
this and um
do the do the coaching is just what i
need to do yeah cool very cool it's
obviously working huh yes yeah
congratulations thank you well thank you
so much for all the help and the
leading of this and so you said the key
to getting out is intentional
intentionality and communication uh what
about you alan what do you say the key
to getting out is for me it was about
legacy um
i came from some challenges in my life
and um if i can do it anyone can do it
um
and so to break that chain
and to create a legacy um that was my
why changing the family tree yes
for our listening audience uh alan is
holding a classic that dave talks about
has talked about for decades the
tortoise and the hair the children's
book that's a good looking addition
there
uh i gotta set you up you brought that
for a reason you've been holding on to
it why does that mean so much to you to
bring it today well ten years is a long
time yes sir yeah i think yeah
but slow and steady wins the race and um
we're 40 years old when we started this
and now uh we're positioned to retire
inspired
yeah you have zero debt house or
anything you live in california hello i
mean that's a big deal yep that's a big
deal you make really good money and you
have not a payment in the world nope
was it worth it absolutely absolutely
it's a long run it is long run how does
it feel to be free
it's amazing
you know knowing that
he can work or not work
you know he can retire early
we can spend more time at the vacation
home in arizona
spending more time with our grandkids as
well so yeah here we go game home yep
good job you guys very very good job
outside of the two of you outside your
family who was the biggest cheerleaders
we have our kids here with us um my mom
was a really big supporter
we had a lot of friends who thought that
it was a great idea for us
you know meanwhile they're taking out
new 30-year mortgages
at our age
and
so a friend of ours
gave us
a little gift of a unicorn when we paid
off our first mortgage in 2019
because there really wasn't anyone
around us you know doing that so
um
you know we've tried to encourage people
you know i mean
we can do it anyone can do it absolutely
you know southern california it's it's
such a rat race everyone's caught up
like a hamster in the wheel
um and concepts like peace
contentment and freedom that they're
foreign when you're on that wheel
and when you're on the other side
it's it's unexplainable
you said something alan earlier i don't
want the audience to miss i'm just
curious how you would uh explain to us
you said you had a tough past is is
basically what i heard you had a really
interesting pass and you said if i can
do it anybody can do it what are you
taking away from that what do you mean
what do you want the audience to
understand about that when i right after
i met him
sorry um in the mid 90s
he was homeless
and
behind drugs and alcohol
and
you know just
knowing that just one foot in front of
the other
support from those around you
anything's possible yeah
for a point in my 20s i got into
mountain climbing
and
i found it's better not to look at the
summit just look at what's in front of
you one step after another oh wow
that's good
it took 10 years but we're here you're
on top of the mountain absolutely
[Laughter]
well i got to tell you man when you come
through that house sweet it is
[Laughter]
i love it congratulations man that's
powerful
man i'm fired up yeah i'm with you you
uh you've conquered some serious stuff
in your life this debt was it was just
another one absolutely
one more down i like it
that's a warrior yeah we right after we
finished the fpu class actually we had a
major disaster at our vacation home in
arizona and a flood came through town
that was about
a hundred year flood and the water came
up to the windows
and um
you know so
we got knocked down a few times along
the way
it's not an easy road
but you just keep getting up yeah you
know you just keep doing it day after
day yeah that's powerful very good stuff
you guys all right bring the guys in
what are their names and ages so we have
eight aiden who is 18.
and we have aaron who is 14. all right
perfect stuff yeah that's the
three-year-old there now he's 13. i love
it
good stuff all right we got a copy of
baby steps millionaires for you uh you
probably already that without real
estate paid for in california how do
ordinary people build extraordinary
wealth how you can too and also a copy
of total money makeover you can give
that away in your coaching and stir up a
ruckus with somebody we're so proud of
you guys you're amazing people what
heroes thank you absolutely phenomenal
thank you for sharing your story with us
very nice
690 000 paid off in nine years and 11
months making 200 to 400 allen and anya
aidan and aaron from long beach 100
debt free count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
three two one
we're
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dead love it
this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you for joining us america ken
coleman ramsey personality is my co-host
today as we answer your questions about
your life and your money
uh briana is with us in orlando hi
brianna how are you
hi dave i'm doing well thanks for asking
how about you guys better than we
deserve what's up
um i was calling because my husband and
i were recently talking about our
finances and whether or not we should
pay our medical bills first or
or take care of the credit card debt and
things of that such and he mentioned
that
we
we don't need to pay the medical bills
because they are going to fall off in
seven years and i was like well i don't
really think that's true
so we were debating on that and i was
like well let's just call dave and
he's like great
great
oh terrific i'm taking you to the
principal's office great
okay well the answer is uh yes and no
okay
the medical bills uh
uh the debt does not go away in seven
years
uh you still owe it morally and legally
uh and they still can pursue you after
seven years the what the seven year mark
is the yes part is it does come off of
your credit bureau report if there's
been no activity on it for seven years
any credit that is at that activity it
restarts the seven year clock but
all credit good and bad comes off of
your credit bureau report after seven
years except a chapter seven bankruptcy
which stays on ten years but that does
not mean that you don't owe the money
and it does not mean that they can't
come after you legally and it does not
mean they won't hassle the crap out of
you or the stupid thing pop back up in
some way just about the time you're
trying to buy a house or something
so you do need to take care of them
okay how old are they
uh well just about two years they're
from
so we're talking about we're gonna sit
around on our butts for five years and
hope they disappear
bad plan yeah okay
so how much debt is there how much
medical debt is there
uh 3 500. oh it's nothing what do you
guys make yeah
55 a year okay
okay
so it's tight we're also paying
60 16 000 on student loan debt
um we've got a little bit in a credit
card so we're just also trying to
look into buying a home for our family
and we're growing
so
yeah i know i'm gonna stay at home mom
and just want to help
in some way so i thought the best thing
i could do is just kind of start
tackling all this stuff so okay all
right so here's what the two of you need
to sit down tonight put the kids to bed
and you you're gonna have to have a
better dream than you've got
your dream your dream for your life is
awfully small and i want you to dream a
little bigger
because you and i both know you're too
broke to buy a house anytime soon
yeah yeah we're in a one bedroom right
now and we were trying to do the live
like no one else so we can live like no
one else but
we just the kids just keep getting
bigger and we
so now what you've got to do is you have
to get real serious about it and it's
not just cutting
your lifestyle it's now getting on a
written budget and making every dollar
behave
listing these debts smallest to largest
attacking them in that order and he
needs to be on board about that too
right now it's just you doing it isn't
it
yes there yeah i can feel it i can feel
it you're carrying the weight of it
you're the one trying to get this car
started and he's going well it does not
pay the bill they'll go away
so he's going to be looking at some
extra work and you're going to be
looking at some extra work in and around
you being at home with the kids
i don't know what that is it could be
something you can do while they're
napping or something else there's all
kinds of ways to create income ken what
are some of the best ways you've seen
people create income in a stay-at-home
situation like that well we saw through
the pandemic gave a lot of uh jobs that
bubbled up where they were all remote
and so now with the little ones that
does present some challenges but it
depends on the type of work if it is uh
customer service work when she's on the
phone with people and the kids may be
going crazy that would not work per se
however if it's data entry or
a lot of women are making really good
money dave now as remote executive
assistants and so they can do a lot of
scheduling a lot of things over email i
start to look at things like that for a
stay at home mom where there are four or
six hours maybe even steal two or three
hours a night once the babies are in bed
now that is going to be tiring but on
the other side of this is freedom stuck
in a one bedroom a bill's hanging over
your head's tiring too yes it is and uh
boy that'll motivate you to work those
hours because then you start to go why
am i working all these crazy hours to
get out of this one bedroom to get out
of this paycheck to paycheck living that
is so stressful because here's the thing
what you're describing to us brianna is
uh 20 000
changes your life
that's correct you'd be dead free yeah
now i'm just going to use this 20 000
bucks okay yeah that's a part-time job
for one year right he makes 55 i believe
she said she did okay so just to give
you an example
walmart right now dave
is advertising nationally on this
they're paying truck drivers
starting at 90 to 110 000 a year driving
a truck now i'm not saying that's his
career in his long-term life but i'm
saying okay what could we do for a year
or two years to radically change our
future and this is the hottest job
market we've ever been in so yes we want
to reduce expenses we want to get on a
budget but what could he do to get
serious to say we're going to change our
family tree and raise his income from 55
to 75 to 85 if she can make 15 to 20 you
said almost one year you're free one
year not five
with a thing hanging over your head
later and coming back and getting you
100 and if he's sitting in front of me
right now i'd tough love he might say
look bro uh in two months or less i
could show you how to pay off that 3 500
medical bill in two months two months of
extra work you deliver pizza
you're done walmart and target are
paying all ships starting at 20 an hour
amazon
offering 20 an hour fulfillment centers
all over the place
and listen if you have a pulse they'll
hire you
yeah so the the entry levels what i'm
trying to say is realistically even the
posters question but
i knew as soon as i said that and you
know what if you've been to walmart late
at night
hey
all right never mind
but there is here's the point there is
an opportunity right now to go to work
yeah and gazelle intensity includes
working a lot of hours
we talk to couples we talk to
individuals all the time on that debt
free stage over there but that's the
dream see the dream is 20 000 gets you
out of debt
another ten thousand dollars is your
emergency fund now we're saving for a
house
so 20 000 gets you out of debt 20 000
more gets you in an emergency fund under
down payment yeah and then before you
know we funded our kids future yeah and
and now we've changed our family tree
now we have a legacy so but that that
you know and then you're
and and when you think like that
your your whole spirit your body
everything raises up and you have a
different view
and then you go
3 500
is holding me back yeah it's nothing
it's not 350 000. it's 3 500.
and but what that tells me is when
that's overwhelming you that you're not
above it you're not you're it's crazy
you're laying under it isn't it true and
so there's this this perception thing
yeah
and that's hope that's exactly right you
know i think of
i remember a few years ago dave my kid
went to a youth group at adventist
church and they had this mud run and at
one point he stepped in this really deep
area of mud and i was watching and
laughing my wife's like go help the kid
i'm like no he's got it figured out but
the point was is i watched my son dave
he got stuck for a moment and just like
this financial stuckness we're here on
this call what he's doing is all he's
doing is looking around him he's always
thinking is i'm stuck and this is awful
and i'm embarrassed and whatever a kid
thinks of in that moment
and that's what you're talking about
it's like oh we're month to month and oh
we'll just have to put the bills off
that's looking around ourselves when
we're stuck as opposed to looking up
going okay who can help me where is
there a limb i can grab in financial
peace university and the budget and the
baby steps are that helping hand to
where you can essentially pull yourself
out that's what you got to be focused on
is how do i get out not oh i just got to
stay alive yeah hope deferred makes the
heart sick yeah but when desire comes
it is the tree of life
it's the difference it really is the
difference and so when you set a really
nice big fat juicy dream and you do it
in high definition
hd
lots of clarity on what the dream smells
like what it feels like what it touches
you know the way it looks the way other
people see it then all of a sudden
everything starts to move for you and
that's what's going on here brianna
that's what's going on this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
hey it's john dolone co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host ken coleman
ramsey personality is my co-host today
as we answer your questions about
building wealth doing work you love and
creating
amazing
relationships it's book launch week here
at ramsey dr john dolone on the road
with his brand new book own your past
change your future it is selling uh
we've sold tens of thousands of copies
it's been an incredible week thank you
for your response to it uh dr alone he's
doing a book signing tonight for those
of you in ktar country in phoenix uh
he'll be at the tatum boulevard
barnes and noble at 6 pm tonight
answering questions doing a talk and
signing your books doing pictures
whatever else we need to do it's all
there so come out come out come out if
you're in the phoenix market thanks for
joining us open phones again as i said
triple eight eight two five five two two
five rob is in
denver to start off this particular hour
hey rob how are you
i'm doing well how are you guys better
than i deserve what's up
awesome
my current life insurance company won't
let me add my 14 year old type 1
diabetic son as a rider on my life
insurance so i started a new application
and process with xander and i hope to
get him covered
my bigger concern is that being a type 1
diabetic it seems makes sense to prepare
him
with a life insurance policy now that
carries him into his adult years
the xander rep i was working with said i
can't get him
in his own term policy until he's 18.
i'm worried the older he gets the more
expensive and harder it will be to get
his own policy he's healthy otherwise
he's an athlete active and involved any
recommendations
um i wouldn't worry about it now
in terms of starting to think that far
into the future
some strategies you can do but uh no i
would even if you could buy life
insurance today i wouldn't
um okay because the 14 year old does not
create an income that is
in the event of his uh unbelief and a
horrible event of his passing
you would miss him obviously
but you would not be uh losing an income
that the family counts on and so i i
wouldn't worry about that make sure you
have your emergency fund in place for
medical needs and that you're taking
care of him of course with your medical
insurance all those kinds of things in
place that's more important than
anything else right now and it sounds
like he's doing a good job of treating
and you know living his proper lifestyle
and those kinds of things which is vital
for a diabetic
diabetes as you are discovering is uh
actually
as bad or worse than cancer or a heart
attack for someone to get life insurance
uh and that's because that's why that's
because the long-term prognosis it
affects
the the death rate among that population
and so
absolutely uh
uh as he
starts to move into adulthood and starts
to take on responsibilities and people
are counting on his income
a couple of things he can do
um number one i would continue to
check with if you know 10 years from now
okay when he's 24. he's out of school
he's got his first job he can check with
zander because the life insurance world
is changing every single day on what it
will cover
stuff that they wouldn't even talk about
covering 30 years ago they cover now and
don't even think about it
because they've just got better
statistical
actuarial numbers on you know say a
cancer survivor or
uh certain types of heart procedures and
and they've got better data on it that
that take the fear out of them having to
write a check is what they're worried
about always so anyway uh keep checking
back number one number two
there is a process in the life insurance
world for adults uh called uh
a guaranteed issue they're typically
smaller policies and they're typically
about five to ten x
what normal term is expensive
but you can get a ten thousand dollar
policy a twenty thousand dollar policy
an example of a big one is you can get
mortgage life insurance
which i do not recommend you get if
you're insurable
by term insurance it's it's one-fifth
the cost but if you buy mortgage life
insurance through your mortgage company
it's a gimmick
insurance but it's almost always
guaranteed issue meaning that there's no
medical they just cover you okay
but it's about 5x so you got a 200 000
policy on 200 000 mortgage you're gonna
pay five times for it what you would
have paid for two hundred thousand our
term policy
okay still not bad and still you got at
least the mortgage taken care of if you
died with a couple of little kids and a
wife right
so
you go get those things until you build
enough wealth and then the last thing of
course is to stay out of debt and become
wealthy as quickly as possible become
self-insured he's got a million dollars
in mutual funds and no debt at all when
he's 35 uh he doesn't need life
insurance his wife will be okay
and if he's winning financially if it is
a little bit more expensive then maybe
for the rest of us he can still afford
it you know
dave i love your advice of checking back
later i i there's no way to make
predictions on this rob but i'm not
kidding you i listened to an enormous
amount of uh sports radio in the car and
i kid you not i heard some i heard a
company the other day advertising on
this very issue so i i think it's the
ball continues to move you know what i
mean xander and other insurance
companies they're going to be options
and if he's financially secure he's
going to be able to afford it if you're
hearing something on sports radio it's
probably guaranteed issue yeah okay yeah
it's um you know it's probably not a
policy that you might get unless you're
uninsurable yeah but if you're
uninsurable then there's a cut you can
backfill with a few of these expensive
policies right great savings plans
great budgeting
not building up a bunch of expenses that
are left behind if something happened to
you and of course most of all managing
your health that's it and um sounds like
he's very healthy young athlete well it
sounds like he's got parents that are on
the ball because it's
everything to do with um
diabetes is tremendously affected by
lifestyle yeah and i'm not a medical
person but i've been around the
insurance side of this thing for a long
time and we see it all the time so
that that's that's what you're looking
for but he's going to be okay rob yeah
and uh because he's got a great dad and
mom
and uh and it's not going to be
something that uh
that's going to be easy it's not a hot
knife through butter to take care of but
you can do those things and and take
care of it for sure good question open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five now again i'm not an
expert on diabetic anything but
um
a lot of the things that drive life
insurance prices
are under your control
that's correct smoking and obesity are
the two biggest things that will cause
your life insurance to double or triple
and these are two things that are under
control under your control
um you know it makes you think of jay
cutler of nashville native you know
played at vanderbilt went on to play in
the nfl uh type one diabetes played in
the nfl i mean he took care of himself
still does you know so you can while it
is a serious disease i have a first
cousin who has it but she manages it
well and there are ways that you can be
healthy even with that
condition absolutely absolutely so
you know i
you quit smoking for a year yeah
you get your life insurance half full
it's the truth yeah half off yeah i mean
it's it's
pretty stinking incredible yeah so these
are these are things you control
and and it's weird how all of these
things
in that case not in
rob's son's case yeah type one and
fourteen it's not that's not the case
not a lifestyle problem that's right but
uh but
you can control a lot of stuff out there
folks this is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 000
about two years after that i got a
remote job that pays me a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars all thanks to
what i learned at bethel tech you could
be next get started today at
betheltech.net
and get 1 000 to 2500
off of your tuition again it's
betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
it is not good that man
be alone
we're so excited we can go to football
games again
yeah i'm so excited that we can do our
events again
these arenas i have we're back yeah
we've been doing them for a while now
we're going to be in las vegas may the
5th doing an event we'll be in orlando
in may doing an event and doing our
entree leadership summit in orlando in
may it's almost sold out like four
tickets left of that thing available and
guess what the smart conference is back
and what happens if you go to smart
conference ken you get really smart days
that's exactly what happens see just
like that october 22nd in dallas this
fall tickets are on sale now uh ken
coleman will be there he'll be talking
about getting a career a job that you
love that you are passionate about and
that you make more than you ever made in
your life yay
uh all the ramsey personalities will be
speaking we'll be speaking on personal
growth on leadership on uh of course
money
of course dr john deloney will be there
with information out of the new book uh
chain uh own your past change your
future pretty incredible stuff and our
special guests will be craig and amy
groschel from life church he's the
pastor of one of america's largest
churches and they'll be doing a session
on marriage it's going to be incredible
tickets are just 39
it is over half sold out already i know
october 22nd sounds like it's a long way
away but you guys know that all of the
concerts and all
of the sporting events are selling out
early and so we're no exception here at
ramsey so get your tickets right now
before they sell out go to
ramseysolutions.com
events i'm so pumped this is so cool
life is so good good stuff good stuff
good stuff rebecca is with us rebecca is
in indianapolis hi rebecca welcome to
the ramsay show
hi thanks for taking my call sure what's
up
so i'm the cfo of a small business and i
would like to know how randy or other
businesses that you know
are determining what fair pay is now
considering the recent inflation
most businesses can't afford to just do
a sweeping eight percent payroll
increase across the board and even if
they can it doesn't mean that that
increase is appropriate for all the
roles but employees and managers don't
really want to hear that so i'm just
curious what other people are doing
well to start with i would reset the
table
on the people that work for you
okay
uh people at ramsay hear me say
regularly
uh your raise is effective when you are
i i you know
we have never given an inflation raise
in the history of this company nor will
we
okay well you are paid for two based on
two things inside of our company
uh you are paid what the position pays
in the marketplace
and that's fair and that's right and
truthfully anybody that's got a job out
there you're paid what you can be
replaced for
with rare exceptions
no one pays you twice
what you can be replaced for
uh they pay you what you can be replaced
for that's cold hard facts i know it's
mean i know it's nasty but welcome to
adult land
okay you get paid what you can be
replaced for number one number two
part of what affects what you can be
replaced for is how good at what you are
what you do how excellent you are what
you do and that makes it harder to
replace you and uh so excellence
and you know killing it and dragging it
home when you're adding value to an
organization they want to add value to
your paycheck and so we are adjusting
our comp around here and we've had some
pretty dramatic upward adjustments in
some categories
based on what that position pays
in the marketplace because the cost of
the cost to hire
a project manager the cost to hire a
dev2
a dev3 developer that writes code a cost
to hire an administrative assistant has
gone up pretty dramatically in the last
24 months
more than any 24 month i remember in 30
years of doing business
okay and ken you've seen this in the
career data so the first thing you need
to do is keep a comp study going and
really know what
each position
what you'd have to pay if you were going
to replace that person because the
marketplace is now if you are a dev2 you
can demand x
you know and if you're a you know if
you're a senior level uh software
engineer you know you're six figures
plus
maybe 200 000 plus
and uh so you know that that's that's
what you can get somewhere else and so
if i don't pay you that you're gonna
leave and go take that and so that's the
way the business is is you you do that
now but that doesn't mean we give
everybody eight percent raises because
the news says inflation was eight went
up eight percent you can't afford to do
that number one number two it's not fair
number three it doesn't make sense from
a business perspective
from a business perspective as a cfo
your job in hiring is to get a rate of
return on every dollar of payroll
and that's based on their productivity
not based on inflation
that's right and i want to add in really
quick rebecca listen
to help and by the way you need to
communicate this but the reality is
let's play this out they think that they
should get a bump for inflation so if we
play that reasoning out that means you
take it away as soon as inflation begins
to subside and they wouldn't be cool
with that either so this compensation is
never built on and should not be built
on inflationary pressures in the economy
it's about profit and loss and as dave
said value and it's the marketplace does
set the bar the marketplace does and so
i would tell you this is not a
compensation or inflation issue what you
have is a leadership issue and this is
hard
but you've got to communicate this
properly to your team and one of the
ways that you need to do this is i would
really engage with smart dollar ramsey
solutions uh there's nothing
com comes close to what we offer the the
business marketplace in helping their
employees
get control of their finances like we do
with individuals on the show every day
we help business leaders help their team
get financial peace in the form of smart
dollar and it's one of the most sought
after benefits uh throughout the nation
and i've been on fox businesses with
maria bartoroma talking about this this
is one of the greatest benefits that
leaders can offer in a time like this
because here's what we know
everybody that works and i'm speaking as
an employee a team member of ramsey
solutions right now every one of us has
all the tools that we need to adjust our
lifestyle
our budget
to the inflationary pressures it's
called a budget it's called financial
peace and i think that's what you need
to invest in them because this is going
to not only help them deal with the
increased cost in gas and groceries just
using two buckets that are real right
now it's a real stressor
but if we can help them manage their
day-to-day budget their monthly budget
and win in the now you're also setting
them up to win in the future they're
going to stay with you a long time so i
i think smart dollar and leading your
team through how to handle their money
in times like this to where inflation
yeah it sucks but it's not rocking our
world
well here again here's the thing we
share
profits with our team that's correct the
profit sharing program and so ramsey
family does not take all the money and
put it in our bank account when there's
profits we share it with the team the
systematic process that we used to do
that we did it since we're a little
bitty company
and so we believe in sharing
but we've never paid someone based on
what it cost a gal what a gallon of gas
cost
uh you don't want to be paid on that no
because at one minute it's five dollars
another time it's two dollars yeah and
you will you want me to cut your pay
it's a roller coaster in half
let me cut your payment that makes no
sense you know the work we're using the
gas pump index to set your pay this
month that'd be popular yeah right and
so no
so we don't pay based on what the costs
are at the grocery store
but here's the weird thing
okay
all of these inflationary things have
driven up
wages that is almost every category
that's right and oh guess what that adds
to inflation because almost every good
or service you buy has built into the
cost of it payroll yeah
and so you buy a loaf of bread it's not
just the cost of the wheat that's right
or the plastic around it it's the cost
of the guy who baked it the guy who
delivered it the gas prices that
delivered it the guy who said gal who
said it on the shelf whoever it was
right so labor labor labor labor labor
fuel
oh there's some wheat in there and
there's your bread right
and so
uh all the increa you know labor went
from ten dollars an hour to twenty
dollars an hour all of a sudden and
guess what that shows up in your loaf of
bread yes
and so but also that means that the guy
buying the loaf of bread went from ten
dollars to twenty dollars an hour
because that's what it takes to get to
hire somebody in entry-level positions
these days so i don't have any of those
positions but all of our positions just
about every category we have our comp
studies we've seen tremendous increases
not based on inflation but based on what
it takes to hire someone into that
position and then that becomes an
element of inflation
with trickle-down economics for those of
you that don't know what that means this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
this hour
on the ramsey show in the lobby of
financial peace university on the debt
free
stage brett and mary are with us hey
guys how are you good
cool welcome good to have you guys so
where you guys live harrisburg north
carolina all right cool welcome to
nashville and how much have you paid off
127 000. all right very good and how
long did this take you 35 months almost
36. okay cool and your range of income
during that time
it started out at 127 and then thanks to
kova it went down to 97
and
then back up to 118 and this year we
should be back to where we started 127.
cool what do y'all do for a living
i'm a counselor for a large hospital
system in the charlotte area
and i'm a network engineer and a voice
over ip specialist ah very good good for
you guys
wonderful what kind of debt was 127
15 of it was typical sally may and then
another 12 000 of it was one of those uh
10-year student loan forgiveness
programs that we figured out doesn't
work yeah
and then um 100 000 of it was our
mortgage oh
look at the weird people
paid for a house
well done you guys what's the house
worth
uh the current market's uh 325 350. nice
and it's all yours yes
cool how long y'all been married 18
years you ever been 100 debt free since
you've been married
nope nope nope first time
i love it how does it feel feels great
it does feel great so tell us the story
what happened three years ago that got
you started on this
a couple of things um i know you're a
car guy i'm uh well we're both members
of a local car club in the area and
just
by coincidence on the way home from
those meetings every month
your show was on and it was just on the
radio one day when we started the car
and it started out as just entertaining
to listen to and then it just started to
make more sense the more i listened to
it then i started to bother them
yeah and then so you know i just started
listening to it every day um you know on
my walks and then um
it just it just made sense what you were
saying made sense so um
we just got focused on it basically
the 10-year
student loan
when i see those statements you know
you don't have to make any payments on
them but that doesn't mean you're not
charging interest and when i see those
statements come in with all the interest
on them and just the thought that we
might have to pay all that back one day
realized we needed to yeah you gotta
clear this up now once you got started
you just plowed on through the the house
and everything huh yep wow funny story
about this though because
he kind of put us on the plane without
having a conversation to me about it
i'm going to be honest here dave your
name was cursed a little bit at my house
i can't imagine
i can tell he violated every counselor's
law
[Laughter]
until
we sat down and went over the budget and
i saw that there was a budget for a
vacation and i saw that there was money
in our my new car fund and i saw that
there was money
you know how it was strategically placed
wow and after that i was like okay sold
i'm done i'll be quiet wow
just like that no
it reminds me of what's going on
she don't go along but she can be bought
she can be
yeah yeah yeah that's right
that was that was after the student
warnings were paid for
yeah yeah he wants to make that clear
yeah happy wife happy life i mean we all
know that yeah
we didn't we didn't do any vacation
under any of that when we were paying
off student loan debt for sure but you
got now where you can and then you did
the normal stuff you should have been
doing it baby steps four through six
right where you're
enjoying your life but being intentional
and then you knock the house out right
and it still knocks out because you had
a very small mortgage and knock it all
out within the whole 36 months that's
very impressive y'all very well done
you're heroes man this is i'm proud of
you
very cool thank you we're honored to be
here too so thank you so much for having
us well we're honored to have you you're
powerful this is good stuff okay now
brett and mary you've done it you're 100
debt free house and everything first
time in 18 years of marriage
what is the secret to getting out of
debt when someone says how did you do
that what do you tell them
uh having a written plan having a budget
um
we were never terrible with money um you
know we never got in serious you know
money issues
i'd throw just one day i decided to put
300 on the mortgage the next month
400 on the mortgage but i didn't have a
plan because i didn't want to spend too
much
because i didn't know how much money we
had because i didn't have a written plan
so once i saw on paper it's just like
getting the raise it really is you
realize
the vacation fund and pay extra on the
market
and pay extra on the mortgage you can do
it and we know every month exactly how
many extra dollars we had to pay
on the mortgage so that's what we did
all right so dave i've got to ask
because for years decades you've said if
you live like no one else later you can
live and give like no one else and i'm
not going to ask a gift question because
i got to ask a live question you're
totally debt free you guys are members
of a car club is there like a dream car
coming
is there one already in the driveway do
we know what are we looking at here well
believe it or not there's no car coming
but um we're actually on our honeymoon
also on this trip here because
we didn't have the money to do that when
we got married oh so that's awesome and
so that's first there we go we are on
vacation we're paying for it and we're
on vacation good that's great
where all are you going nashville and
what else just that was our dream to
come to nationals that's it
at the time so we're doing it 18 years
later that's the way to go i love it
ah well welcome we're so glad to have
you that is so good all right now once
you do all that you got to buy a car
what's the car yeah you guys are car
people yeah
you dodged that question to get husband
points and it was a good move
it was a good move in his defense he
does
he has collected cars over the years and
one he inherited which was his father's
and it was a 1984 um mustang
and so he has other mustangs um we're
probably going to work on the fun for me
because i'm rocking 239 thousand miles
on a honda so yeah
all right okay you're up so there you go
you're up you're up you're up to bat but
i haven't decided because i'm going to
cry when i let go of that car wow
that's so cool tears of joy
well i love my car i just love it
dave
trust me we saw your raptor earlier sir
[Laughter]
it's down there in the reserve spot no
doubt about it i love it good job guys
that's fun you're fine well this was
about living and giving like no one else
and it just in euros case what i keep
hearing over and over again was a you
got together and b
uh just the intentionality it took the
it took the sloppy edges out of what was
already a frugal lifestyle already a
fairly reasonable lifestyle you were not
out of control
as you said brett but all you did was
just tighten it up by being intentional
by making everything behave and do what
it's supposed to do what you wanted it
to do you get to choose and you chose oh
wisely well done
very very well done good work good work
proud of you guys we're honored to have
you here with us well thank you very
much for that thank you very much got a
copy of baby steps millionaires for you
that's definitely the next chapter in
your story how ordinary people built
extraordinary wealth how you can too a
bestseller we're going to give you also
give you a copy of our best-selling book
we've ever done at ramsey the total
money makeover you can give that to
someone else and stir up a holy ruckus
with them get some stuff going on there
i love doing that so good stuff thanks
again guys for being here brett and mary
from charlotte north carolina 120 7 000
paid off house and everything in 35
months they're officially weird making
127 000 count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
three two
one
[Applause]
boom
you gotta love it
gotta love it
we've had in the last month or so a
24 year old
a 20 and a 74 year old
and uh and everything in between and
since the first of the year
almost 22 million dollars in debt-free
screams wow uh pretty incredible pretty
incredible and uh get to talk to
millionaires baby step millionaires
every day
uh as we go out and sign books and as
they call in here people meeting people
that have been doing this stuff
and you're listening today maybe for the
first time
i sure hope
that you think this is more than mere
entertainment
i sure hope you decide to go change your
life it's why we show up and do this
every day it's for you
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
so
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today our scripture of the day
is first peter 5 10 and the grace of god
who called you to his eternal glory in
christ after you have suffered for a
little while will himself restore you
and make you strong firm and steadfast
dr martin luther king jr said the
ultimate measure of a man is not where
he stands in moments of comfort and
convenience but where he stands at times
of challenge
and controversy
one of his better quotes and he was a
quote machine for sure
wow what a what a man all right k is
with us in denver colorado hey kay
welcome to the ramsey show
thank you how are you doing today better
than i deserve what's up
i lost my husband seven months ago to
cancer oh my and
yeah and we never
decided whether we were going to
purchase
the home for our three kids or whether
we were going to make a large down
payment for them
and now i'm kind of like what do i do
purchase your your three children are
grown and you wanted to buy them homes
as adults is that what you're saying yep
yep that's what we're saying
okay
all right
wow
so you're obviously in a very good
position financially
i
ran into this book in 2009 called total
money makeover
and it just stopped franks and my
we own
a business and it just stopped our life
and we just turned around and got
ourselves debt free wow
wow
okay
i'm so sorry uh how old was he
he was 64.
going on 46.
i want that on my tombstone i love him
already what a great guy
oh my gosh
and you have three kids and they're all
grown
are they all married
they're all married okay
all right
and um what is your net worth now
uh four million good for you okay
and so you're talking about
buying a house price of what per kid
i'm i have one in portland so
kind of 500 000 i have one here in the
denver area so another 500 000 and i
have one in minnesota and i think i
could do 300 000.
okay or 500 or whatever if you did just
did
so million five of your
would leave you at two five right
um yeah but that includes my home
yeah so cash pretty big
three million yeah it's a pretty big hit
cut your cash in half
um
but a million i just got from from him
so in my mind you know he's paying for
two out of three kids right now
[Music]
how old and you're how old
57. how old are they
the kids what's the range um 38
36 34.
okay
are you planning to stay in the business
you're going to sell the business what's
that paying you
i'm planning to stay in the business and
it could pay me
anywhere from
you know like this last year i did i
really didn't work and i made 50 000. um
i'm sure i won't go back like i was so i
don't know 50 to
150 200 000 probably what i could make a
year
but for the last five years we kind of
retired in 2017
because this cancer hit four times
and so i would work and
um
that would be our play money we take the
kids here or we do this or we do that
okay i um love the idea of helping the
kids
and um
uh
but but the pre the the caveat has to be
that you're okay first
and um a million and a half out of
this is
uh i it's it's it's it's pushing my fear
button a little bit for you
okay
it's not a million and a half out of 11
million it's half your cash
and um
so um
i'm probably going to do this in two
stages if i'm you
like a max of 300 per kid
and so that uses a third of your cash
not half of your cash right
and
that might buy the one in uh minnesota
or wherever it was the full house i
don't know and to be the down payment
for the other two
and then you're you're working and
making 200 and you look up and your net
worth is 5 million
5 or 10 years from now you pay the other
two off
you know
uh so if i was going to buy the kids the
home i was going to keep
i was going to keep it under
a trust and keep i was going to have the
house
so they couldn't borrow against it so
they couldn't you know ever get in
trouble
i had a friend that paid paid for his
kids houses and he all he asked for was
a letter from each of the kids and their
spouse promising to never borrow a dime
again of any kind and in return you get
a house
and you know you're going through
financial peace and so forth right
and so that's the you know that's the
commitment on their part rather than
trying to protect them from themselves
the best way to protect them from
themselves is not be somebody they need
to be protected from
and so if they're not if they won't be
willing to commit to not turn around and
mortgage it i don't want to give them
one
so the other um the other piece of this
is i have one that's
good to fair with money one that's fair
and one's fair to terrible
so
and so they you know so you know so
you're gonna have to prove to me that
you're worthy of this by quit being fair
to terrible
because otherwise i'm giving a drunk a
drink i have no desire to
give somebody a house that's going to
turn around and it'd be a curse to them
rather than a blessing the whole purpose
of this is to be a blessing
and and i agree and we you know we agree
to that and i understand that but what
if they can't qualify for 300 000
dollar home or 250 000 home yeah well it
may take a little while to execute all
this which will also give you time to
grow some more wealth
no one says you had to do it all today
if they're not ready
okay we started the discussion assuming
i was assuming they were all ready but i
may want to rehab
the behaviors of one of these and get
commitments from the other two and this
might take a year
during which time you're in you know
your your money is invested and it's
going to go up
and um
you know because you're probably not
touching any of this you're probably
just going to make enough to live on i
suspect
yeah that's what we've been doing
um
uh one of the things i've learned is
that generosity sometimes is hard work
surprisingly
it's not given some type you're not
giving somebody 20 at the gas pump
surprise and delight you know random
generosity this is 300 000 bucks to
somebody that you love
and that you know you could be doing
harm to if you don't do it right so it's
going to require a process and you're
grieving
and they're grieving
so um yeah
i don't think the husband you're
describing to me is going to give the
kid that's misbehaving with money money
was he that guy was he an enabler no he
wasn't but his biggest pet peeve is all
these kids rent and as you know rent is
crazy right now
that was just his thing i i agree i'm a
real estate guy too i like it i love the
idea of them all having paid for houses
but i want that to be a blessing to them
and that entails them a handling money
well be committing to never borrow money
again otherwise undoes everything that
his
legacy your legacy that you're trying to
do is doing
so i would just let this unfold a little
bit over time here
let's give this a little time you guys
continue the grieving process it takes a
little while to breathe
um you're doing awfully well on the
phone here
thank you for that that's um
because i was about crying just
listening to you um
but the uh um yeah sitting down with
them and going okay guys i don't know
what i'm doing right now but i'm kind of
thinking out here in the near future uh
fall next spring something like that we
need to be talking about doing this and
here's what i'm thinking and here's my
worries
and uh here's what i think i'm going to
ask you to do
and y'all start processing that and
you know you can do whatever you want to
do but that's the way we would probably
do it around here
if we were doing it so there you go
wow
[Music]
ken coleman good show today thanks sir
good job to james to bend to kelly zach
in the booth i'm dave ramsey your host
we'll be back with you before you know
it in the meantime remember this is
ultimately there's ultimately only one
way to financial peace and that's to
walk daily with the prince of peace
christ jesus here you can find all of
our shows with the ramsey network app on
your smartphone it's the only place to
listen to the entire back catalog of
episodes download the ramsey network app
in your favorite app store today
[Music]
you